under the governor's stay at home 2.0
directive ccsd students are not allowed
to play
any sports where close contact cannot be
avoided
in a statement ccsd said if students are
not in our classrooms under
face-to-face instruction it would not be
responsible to have them playing sports
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo on
this issue speaking to sports organizers
who are providing an outlet for students
it's a huge blow for these kids
ben joffe is a director of operations
for national youth sports nevada
he feels for these kids and wants to
keep their drive
going we finished our fall season we fed
it we're in the middle of our winter
season right now we're running
baseball we're running flag football
running girls volleyball and soon we'll
launch the spring season which includes
soccer we had a tremendous start to our
winter season we have almost 3
000 kids registered right now safety is
a priority
taking temperatures kova testing for
coaches wearing masks and sanitizing
equipment
there is also a limit of 50 people per
game to be able to provide something
that supplements an
outlet is just it's really it's it's why
we do the job
phase one sports owner mike waters
agrees i think the disheartening part
was creating dates and letting people
know that
we will be getting back going soon and
then pushing those dates back
waters believes this makes it more
difficult for athletes to stay focused
and motivated
that's why he says they maintained what
they've been doing all along
i've connected with a few different
programs
just because there are some people out
there that are willing to to go the
extra mile
perrin rennett mills is choosing that as
an alternative
for my son with it being his junior year
we've opted
to join a travel football league in
arizona
mels wants nevada to look at other
states and models
and make it work for kids whether it's
phase one or something similar make sure
your
young athlete stays active sally
jaramillo 8 news now
sally mentioned other states we should
point out that nearly 40
other states across the country are
playing sports and have been for months
ben joff says they are working with the
school district and coaches association
to hopefully run a season for the high
schools in a private way we also reached
out to the ymca they're offering sports
ranging
from basketball to the swim team even
aerial arts
we asked you on twitter do you think
school sports should return
64 percent said yes 36 percent
say no